donc hervé bourges
pour quelles raisons pour quelle raison
le csa a accordé à tf1 qui est déjà
riche à milliards
deux minutes de plus de pub par heure
pour quelles raisons
puis coupez la décision qui a été prise
à l'époque est une décision juridique
parce que c'était le droit commun c'est
tout voilà donc à faire ce cadeau à tf1
c'est le cadeau c'est vous qui le dites
moi j'ai rien d'autre à cantley chaînes
commerciales deux minutes le plus de
plumes c'est un cadeau qu'on lui fait
dans ma poche et rien d'autre à ajouter
ont valu 6 par rapport aux j'espère que
tout le monde l'a éteint la lumière
pendant la question qui tue à la maison
et même ferment d'autres tout aussi
fernando tu dois éteindre la lumière
moi j'ai une question sur le csa oui
parce que je trouve que vous verrouillez
beaucoup mais parfois vous n'êtes pas
sur le coup il ya un truc qui me choque
beaucoup c'est des bandes annonces de
films violents ça que moi j'aime bien
parfois comme tout père de famille
j'aime bien parfois pouvoir laisser mon
gosse devant la télé quand ça m'arrange
quelques minutes et à des heures où ou
c'est pas trop dangereux et parfois il
ya des bandes annonces et remet à partir
du moment où je vais vous le dire ou le
film a eu tel signalétique et que bon
ben on n'a pas à ce moment là à dire
quoi que ce soit sur la bande mais vous
avez raison les bandes sont souvent
comme tout ça rires oui comme tout comme
tout pub un raccourci violent mais moi
je vais vous dire une chose je n'aime
pas ça comme je n'aime pas non plus ceux
qui font de keane qui sont qui sont pour
la drogue
moi je suis tout à fait qu'on est pas
pour la légalisation je suis content et
je vais vous dire une chose terrible
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et d'amitié pour
vous le savez j'aime pas quand dans vos
émissions vous poser la question sur le
cabba niche qui prévoit 20 oui le
caractérise
et c'est ok mais non mais non moi je moi
je vais vous dire une chose raison
président moi je suis contre je suis
content je suis content que je dis que
chacun fait ce qu'il veut dans son coin
mais
dans une émission et notamment une
mission de service public on veut pas
faire la promo de sa retraite qui va
changer dans tout le monde peut aller au
noir et si j'ai un reproche à vous faire
c'est celui largement dalli je vous le
dis comme ça entre nous bien alors
dernière question à un moment vous devez
essayer d'autoriser à la télévision la
publicité pour les sites internet de la
distribution tiers c'était assez bizarre
parce que auchan présent peut pas faire
de pub show à la télévision mais au
shampooing comme pouvait en faire oui
mais son essai a été refusé
je vais vous dire une chose nous avons
interprété la loi si vous voulez le
conseil jeudi pour ceux qui ne jouent
pas pour les gens branchés qui
connaissent tous le cssa ni pour la
petite société parisienne je parle pour
le grand public que vous avez bravo il
murmura barbeau qui nous regardent il
faut dire que le conseil supérieur
audiovisuel ne fait pas de l'oas à ce
parlement ne fait pas de décrire ça
c'est le gouvernement mais un est une
autorité indépendante qui peut
interpréter la loi nous avons interprété
la loi nous avons dit la loi ne
concernait pas internet donc nous
pensons que la publicité sur internet
est une bonne chose et beaucoup de
journaux et beaucoup d'autres pensé que
c'était une bonne chose et le conseil
d'état nous a donné tort très bien
résidents nous alignons viry sous vos
yeux thierry enfreint la loi pour
argumenter dans une conversation il cite
une marque et vous ça passe comme une
lettre à la lièvre 16 mairie à sa
liberté de parole et qu'il a toujours eu
et c'est un quand j'étais président de
tf1 de france télévisions ou quand je
les présidents du csa bien dernière
question quand dominique baudis a été
nommé par le président chirac vous êtes
un petit peu prononcée l'an un pcb ou
implicitement comme vous dites ça veut
dire quoi implicitement on voulait me
dire vous étiez pas très souvenir que je
n'ai rien dit non j'ai rien à dire que
j'en arrive unique nome qui veut
rayonner monsieur baudis
eh bien monsieur baudis et des océans
maison du style d'un mélanome et yves
voilà voilà que je n'ai rien à dire et
je souhaite que le sait ça continue à
être cet organisme indépendant impartial
et protège la liberté de la
communication et qu'il nomme par
consensus des présidents de chaînes à la
hauteur pour conclure là dessus quand
vous avez rencontré jacques chirac à
l'elysée vous êtes sorti en disant il
fera ce qu'il voudra et vous engueuler
chirac un peu vous avez rencontré
jacques tu j'ai rencontré jacques chirac
que comme président du conseil supérieur
audiovisuel avant de partir j'ai vu le
président dary
mik le président du sénat monsieur fonds
serait le président d'assemblée monsieur
fourni pour parler du csa pas du tout on
a parlé de l'avenir du seuil ça ne m'a
pas dit qu'il allait nommer une
mastectomie rien dit vous avez la
meilleure preuve que tout cas eu aucun
problème c'est cuit jours après il
partait pour le sommet france-afrique
eisel danse et la gym années j'étais son
avis des personnels